okay let's go next to our caller from
the 4:03 who's calling today from 4 0 3
4 0 3 are you there hmm
4 0 3 last chance before I have to move
on hi that's me can you hear me yes I
can
hello yes I can read uh quick question I
was just wondering if you are worried
about a nationalist or protectionist
slide due to the Cova 19 situation what
kind of a policy would make that evident
you know what I'm not too sure I did
just recently see a survey that's New
York parents obviously they really want
things like summer camps to start again
yep but they're really worried about
foreign camp counselors that type of
thing I'm just wondering if you could
see the average American kind of sliding
more towards that they weren't already
on that I mean the funny thing about
I'll address that directly but the funny
thing about that is there's so many
countries that are doing better than the
United States so the idea that we're
more at risk if there are foreign camp
counselors seems a little silly I mean I
think that in practice it's not going to
be a huge thing because it's it's very
likely that particularly international
travel is going to remain pretty
depressed through the fall if not even
longer that's my prediction one area
where I'm hearing a kind of nationalist
surge is we have to re nationalize our
supply chain so you know we can't be
getting a 95 mass from China we can't be
getting medical equipment from this
country or that country so that is a
nationalist push that I've been seeing
which is we a lot of the stuff we buy
internationally we should be producing
domestically which of course will make
it much more expensive I mean this has
always been the debate when it comes to
outsourcing production of stuff we
always could do it we just have an
economy based on getting it cheaply from
somewhere else I am seeing now more
discussion of we've got to bring the
supply chain inside the borders
definitely and I see that kind of that
lean Justin
you know you get your product and
immediately it shipped out yep that
could be coming into question over the
next few years too anyways thanks a lot
for the question um big fans show a long
time member thank you very much all
right thank you very much excellent all
right let's take a quick break if you're
holding please don't hang up because I
will go I'm gonna go back to the phone
so quickly you're not even going to know
what hit you right after this short
break